chanson dans l'eau et grâce aux masques
à la distanciation et aux précautions
sanitaires
il retrouve enfin le plaisir de chanter
en choeur les intervenants de la gagne
un rang brou ont fait ce qu'il fallait
pour reprendre les activités de jour
destiné aux personnes vivant avec une
déficience intellectuelle ou de
l'autisme ou cédés à des tanks même l'or
de l'or
ouais c'est pas noël
simulation danielle godet craint les
conséquences de l'isolément et de
l'inactivité sur sa fille de 37 ans qui
est privé de son emploi dans un
programme spécial depuis le printemps
qui est habitable
je me suis dit j'ai pas pour écouter la
musique fait du défunt la journée longue
où aller se coucher et des personnes qui
se sont retrouvées chez eux tout seul du
jour au lendemain plus d'accès à l'école
à la formation plus d'accès au travail
compagnons de montréal un organisme
communautaire a recommencé à accueillir
des stagiaires qui pourront un jour
occuper un emploi malgré leurs
différences avec le retour qu'on le fait
graduellement de nos activités soit en
insertion socioprofessionnelle soit au
centre d'activités de jour on ne
réalisait que certaines personnes
avaient perdu des acquis cognitives la
directrice de l'organisme estime que
l'ensemble des services doivent
reprendre au plus vite
y compris dans le réseau public comment
ça se fait que les activités menées par
des groupes communautaires arrive à
offrir des activités stimulantes en
milieu sécuritaire alors que le réseau
avec ses grandes ressources n'y arrive
pas encore la direction des services aux
sus centre sud de montréal parle plutôt
d'établir des priorités en ce moment on
est encore un pandémie on voit qu'on a
encore pour plusieurs mois donc en ce
moment toute l'organisation et toute la
reprise est là est fait en fonction de
ça une directive ministérielle rappelle
aux gestionnaires du réseau de la santé
que les activités services qui
préviennent le déconditionnement doivent
être maintenus voire même intensifier en
même temps qu'on reprend ses services
des personnes qui étaient déjà inscrits
faut penser aux gens qui étaient en
attente basse canucks se sont
détériorées aussi pendant la première
vague qui ont vécu ce difficilement
aussi on à paris ils prennent 7 ce temps
l'or justement pas offert des coupures
et de d'envoyer plus la communauté est
ce que tu aimes et chinois tout le monde
l'entend mais oui hein
en attendant son retour au travail
marie-josée se réfugie dans la musique
ici à nourrice despatie radio canada
montréal
[Musique]